online because I just
got back playing with my uh with my kids
and getting ready for the uh the
Festival of Lights which we maybe we may
be lighting up with fusion-powered
energy in the near future so let's see
there's eight people watching
they can hear us Charles how are you
today professor Charles Seifer I'm doing
well thank you very much great you are a
rare two-time guest on the into the
impossible podcast and an audience uh
demand recently thanks to this novel
result released recently
from Lawrence Livermore National
Laboratory up north here in Northern
California and we're going to get into
that
and we'll also discuss your book you
were on previously for a wonderful book
called Hawking Hawking which came out in
2021 I was one of my favorite books of
the Year scientific won many awards as
have many of your books and first maybe
you could introduce the fact that you
are a journalist Professor sorry you
were a science journalist but now you're
a journalism professor as well as a
journalist you still write
um what uh what gives you the so much
authority to talk about general
relativity you know quantum mechanics
and now and also fusion and what does a
journalist know tell us Charles well
journalisms are journalists are meta
experts that we we kind of uh are
experts on expertise if we do our jobs
right so we in some ways assemble a peer
review uh which uh for the best science
journalists can sometimes be more
effective and quicker than the peer
review going through the journals I'm
not saying necessarily that I'm I'm the
uh best jury of science but uh what we
do is very much
um in accord with what good science is
and my background is I was training as a
mathematician before I was a journalist
so uh I have a somewhat unusual skill
set within the journalism community and
I've been studying Fusion for actually
my first job I actually wrote about
Fusion uh when I was at the economist
more than uh 25 years ago which kind of
terrifies me so uh yeah it's been a
while and then that eventually must have
played a a some role in this wonderful
book sun in a bottle s-u-n in a Bottle
Let me see if I can get this to work I'm
trying to do so many things here I'm
going to purchase it accidentally but
Charles as may be new to you but not to
my brilliant audience I love always love
to play a game that you're never
supposed to play which is to judge books
by their covers because uh what else do
you have to go with but uh so I'm going
to show the cover now I'm not going to
be able to have the animation I have
this custom-made bespoke animation with
a judge hitting a gavel anyway Charles
you'll watch us another time and we'll
maybe we'll edit it in at some point I'm
going to share the cover there it is
right up now I'm showing it you can buy
it makes a wonderful Hanukkah present
and this darkest day of the year happy
Solstice to you my winter listeners and
also to my friends at the South Pole uh
celebrating the first day of summer so
uh Charles describe the image that my
audience is now seeing there's three
circles uh there seems to be a person
and the title uh and the subtitle is the
most provocative aspect of this book to
me describe this title at book and let
us judge it
well there's there's two versions of the
cover and if you've got the one with a
little person on it it is
um actually the inside of a Tokamak yes
but it's turned on its side uh which
actually always drove me nuts a little
bit about this cover uh but so a Tokamak
is a magnetic bottle for a sun
uh for a for a plasma And So It Goes
Around
um uh confined by the magnetic fields as
you heat it uh to tens and uh hundreds
of millions of degrees Kelvin and
hopefully you keep the pressure up and
confine it tightly enough you get these
atoms to fuse and release more energy
than you put in that's the idea anyhow
and there's another cover well it's
interesting because the cover when I
click on the cover it shows the first
one shows a nucleus by the way is there
a law that says whenever you're showing
something to do with atomic physics you
must always show a lithium atomy it
always has three electrons Charles what
the heck why it's a beautiful symmetry
there yeah and they always have these
nice orbits I mean that's uh obviously
bezel functions aren't as beautiful uh
to show on uh Graphics that's right
that's right
um so we talked as I said about a year
ago about Hawking Hocking I'll put links
to that also in the uh in the show notes
after the video gets a little bit of
love and care after after we're done uh
but the the subtitle has to do with with
um with the notion of basically hype and
I kind of um I kind of thought uh
Incorporated that in the click bait I
mean the thumbnail title uh that I used
which has the word hype because I think
video is an expert on these things and
and I knew there was no one I'd rather
talk to than you about this the subtitle
of the of the copy I'm looking at says
the strange history of Fusion and the
science of Wishful Thinking tell us more
professor
yeah this has kind of been a uh you in
in
Holy Grail
over and over and over again and the
idea of free energy more broadly than
Fusion Energy has been something which
has been uh capturing the ideas of
tinkerers and Alchemists and inventors
and hoaxsters since the beginning of
time and uh only since kind of the uh
Advent of thermodynamics do we know that
we couldn't have a perpetual motion
machine
but fusion
um in some ways offers the next best
thing because if you can convert these
tiny amounts of matter into energy
um you can reveal uh release basically
as much as you want uh
based upon the kind of the most uh
abundant element in the universe you can
theoretically
generate energy like um the stars do so
this has kind of been the uh perpetual
motion machine quest for centuries
um infusion in particular for almost a
century now people thought it was around
the corner for 20 years
and my book was really exploring as much
kind of this phenomenon of fusion as
much as it was how scientists always
managed to get so excited about this
idea that they throw away caution to the
wind and in fact their way sometimes
their scientific method in hopes of
achieving this Quest and which has been
much much harder than people have
anticipated over the years yeah the old
joke was you know it's the energy source
of the future it always will be
that's been used in many many contacts
um let's first talk about Fusion I'm
showing uh figure one or two the fusion
uh sorry I'm showing fission which is
the generation of energy you call it the
sword of Michael what does that mean
yeah
so so
um that was kind of a play on
um Ivy Mike and and uh which was the
first full-on hydrogen bomb test so we
entered the atomic age thanks to World
War II and
um the Manhattan Project after kind of
the Fermi uh had a uh critical Pile in
the University of Chicago I was able to
show that with heavy elements with
uranium uh you were able to get a chain
reaction of fission uh and fission is
where heavy elements heavier than iron
and nickel split apart and when these
heavy elements split apart they release
energy and in the case of uranium
certain isotopes of uranium and
plutonium they also release neutrons
which strike other atoms which split the
atoms which release more neutrons so you
get a chain reaction
so Fermi and the Madden project prove
that you could do this in a controlled
fashion in a pile you get enough
together with a enough moderating rods
that absorb and slow neutrons you can
actually create energy by this breaking
of uh uranium fuel or you could do it in
uncontrolled fashion by
creating a critical mass all together
all of a sudden and getting an atom bomb
so that was the state of the art as of
1945 that's what helped end the war
um after that though the quest continued
um to do not just fission bombs but
Fusion bombs which uh unlike plutonium
and uranium bombs don't have an upper
limit on how big you can build them and
for political reasons Edward Teller
wanted to have these City busting bombs
rather than just the ones which would
devastate downtown Hiroshima and so the
way to do that was figure out a device
that used a fission bomb
to generate enough x-rays to cause
pressure to implode a secondary full of
Light Elements uh isotopes of hydrogen
to cause a fusion reaction which was
even bigger yeah so the primary which is
fission detonates
shines radiation onto the secondary
which implodes and causes a fusion
reaction and that happened in the early
1950s first with what's called a boosted
reaction where you kind of increase the
uh Power of efficient reaction by
injecting neutrons into it in a test
called Greenhouse George and the big one
was Ivy Mike in 1954 November 1951.
um
and all of a sudden we had more energy
than we could want out of a bomb which
is great if you're trying to destroy
cities it's not so great if you want to
generate energy and put it on the Crypt
and so the quest began can we take this
energy and do it in a controlled way
like we do with fission and uh Fermi did
in 1942.
and with uh with the you know kind of
knowledge that stars or giant Fusion
reactors I can't resist but uh to kind
of bring up somebody that is not really
your favorite person to talk about and
that's uh that's Elon Musk and Elon uh
has said that the Quest for
for nuclear fusion is basically a Fool's
errand after all we have a continuous
Fusion reactor that happens to show up
you know once a day never goes on strike
like my graduate students currently are
but I'm not I'm not upset about my
graduences uh at the University of
California I stand with them Union power
uh but they don't go on strike the sun
doesn't go on strike uh it's available
uh well not rain or shine it's there but
um but why go to any trouble whatsoever
then just build more SolarCity you know
Tesla power walls now I know that causes
you trouble because you are an investor
in a competitor to uh to Elon that's
truth social I and I know how much you
no no you you become you're almost the
first person in history to convince me
to go to Mastodon if I have to follow
you on Mastodon freaking Charles you
better you better follow me back uh but
anyway
um is Elon right are you guys making
strange bedfellows uh in some ways I
agree with him that that I I do think
that Fusion at least in the near term is
not going to be practical energy source
however I mean I I think that Elon is
ignoring the fact that we do need good
sources of energy in a practical way
short term and solar is just not going
to cut it and I don't think solar
electric is going to cut it either
um I think that there are other kind of
solar versions that are probably more
practical but
um we can't rely entirely on Renewables
at this point that's just a fact we're
we're burning coal or burning gas or
burning oil that's because it is our
needs aren't taken care of in a
economically viable way
um not just technically viable way so I
think we do need other things out there
to fill in the gap uh whether Fusion is
that answer is another question honestly
I think fission is as many problems as
it has is here now
um and has many of the same advantages
that Fusion does
um so I'm the fact that
um uh traditional fission nuclear is
having so much difficulty and is so
expensive relative to other forms of uh
energy is kind of a sign that even if we
do manage to get a uh fusion power plant
in the next 30 years it's not going to
be a Panacea it's it's certainly
economically uh it's got a lot to uh a
lot of problems to overcome there yeah
and you know when you do these um these
kind of uh deep dives into physics you
do bring first of all you're an
excellent writer and I really enjoy that
and I think it's a rare gift that not
many you know scientists actually have
and and you're not practicing a science
trained as a scientist
um but you also bring this journalistic
ethos where you're really not afraid to
speak truth to power and I've been very
much impressed by your courage and and
kind of you know taking on big fusion
and you know these these other you know
kind of now National Laboratories and
really pointing out the hype and I don't
think it's to sell more copies of a book
you published in 2009 uh but but maybe
you know that will be an ancillary
benefit but I want to go through the
announcement and before we do we're
talking about uh we're talking about
professor Charles seif of uh New York
University who's a two-time guest on the
show first book was Hawking honking
which I just devoured and um and really
resonated with me because you know I
opportunity to meet Hawking once and um
and the only interaction only aspect of
that interaction I remember is that he
did was asked by an audience member when
he could still speak in quasi-real time
why did you write A Brief History of
Time and as I told you last year you
know he replied after five minutes of
you know poking around with his eyes uh
he replied because I needed to pay for
my daughter's private school so at least
he was honest but but there was an
industry and there still is this Mythos
and Ethos surrounding him that really he
solved all these problems and which
really weren't solved or that he was the
sole contributor to many many things it
is of course a shame that he died you
know before his colleague and friend
Roger Penrose passed 12-time guest on
the show
um you know received the award that you
know rightfully maybe Steve would have
participated in as well but the reason I
bring this up is that you know he's a
cherished icon you know there's t-shirts
of him he's as close as we've gotten to
Einstein in our in our age where you and
I are the same age approximately and so
I think we grew up with that and now
we've grown up you know for decades both
with the I mean there are very few
things that can solve you know resource
Wars that can prevent Global further
global climate change and if successful
Fusion could allow unlimited energy to
not only produce energy but to
decarbonize as I understand it could
decarbonize the planet and uh and and
reverse global warming not just not just
halt it so you're taking on powerful
forces
um was there any time you know either
the writing of this book maybe is a long
time before this announcement that we're
about to get to uh but did you ever feel
like the there were press forces that
rather you just shut up and that you had
to use your journalistic you know you're
like an old-fashioned newspaper man
um what what did you ever encounter
threats let me let me just be totally
blunt did you ever feel you were
threatened in any way uh career-wise
intellectually or otherwise
I
heck of a lot of pressure except from
certain Fringe groups um believe it or
not the larouche the Lyndon larouche
Packers were very heavily into fusion
and they really disliked me to made it
known and were trying kind of personally
kind of sending me stuff
um cold fusion backers tended to be
pretty
um Angry uh at me but generally speaking
kind of the scientists most of them were
even the ones on the inside were didn't
didn't have an issue with what I was
saying because they they really the good
ones really admitted it that this really
isn't an energy project for now uh which
is uh if you push them they will they
will tell you frankly if you push the
people at net uh who
um did this announcement they will say
that this is really not practical in the
near term they're going to say that
they're they're on the road to energy
this is a great step forward even though
at the same time they will admit that
nif is primarily a stockpile stewardship
project rather than energy project it
really is meant for nuclear weapons
um
more recently as money has been flowing
into the private sector with Fusion I've
gotten more virulence opposition yeah
um but it's not actually the only time
I've really felt more threatened is not
when I write about physics but right
about biomed and the amount of money
going in there is so much greater that I
don't think the physicists really have
the energy to get angry with me the way
the bio people well I'm reminded of
hearing you say that of a quote by uh a
man whose job title I don't think it
exists anymore Charles tell me if I'm
wrong uh it was muckraker and that's uh
Upton Sinclair who said the following
never argue with a man whose job depends
on not being convinced it's difficult to
get a man to understand something when
his salary depends on his not
understanding it
um so you know I I don't want to I mean
that I think I haven't talked to you
about this but but I assume you'll agree
with this one state treatment
which is that the technology the actual
you know uh the actual laboratory and
Scientific Technology has gone into this
is incredibly impressive now despite the
vast cost of it I mean what is the total
lifetime cost just to construct the
national ignition facility
with projects like this is often hard to
yeah they're a good number
um the number I have heard brought it
about for construction was about 4
billion yeah
um it's almost double that I would say
in terms of kind of Lifetime costs yeah
that's something that by the way just
parenthetically just for my audience is
ultimately incredibly brilliant but
they're maybe younger people whenever
you hear something like oh the LHC
upgrade will cost three billion dollars
that's true it will cost that if you're
right usually you have to multiply by
the famous fudge factor of Pi right but
that just as soon as you want to build
it to just gaze at it you know but but
if you actually want to use the their
own thing it costs about rule of thumb
from the Department of energy for my
friends that work there it's about 10
percent of the construction cost per
year to operate said instrument and it
it's kind of scale and variant across
all different fields including cosmology
so my 100 million dollar Simon's
Observatory that I get to be Pi with and
and lead with my friends at Princeton
and Penn and Berkeley this incredible
project and Chicago this project is
going to cost twice that you know 200
million dollars over a decade
um it's just astounding how much these
things cost so
um uh just notwithstanding or
normalizing out the technology or the
the money I think the technology is is
rather interesting and I think there are
two different forms of of of plasma that
are promising on Earth one is um one is
called inertial confinement which we'll
talk about uh but the other is called uh
is called magnetic confinement or our
alternate confinement and that's to
solve this this triple product and maybe
you can kind of explain what is the
physics behind what it actually has to
come together literally uh and in this
case we'll just stick to deuterium and
tritium and the the the the the
components of this fusion reaction at
the national ignition facility what
needs to be achieved and what have they
actually claimed to achieve
yeah so so to get Fusion you need
um a reasonable amount of energy out you
need high temperatures and pressure and
you need a reasonable amount of
confinement time if these things work
against each other and getting all three
simultaneously is very difficult which
is why you have so many records saying
we'd have the highest temperature ever
in a Tokamak or we've confined for 1200
seconds in a Toka Mac but they don't
talk about the other factors that you
need to kind of get all uh Fusion going
so um
ICF the inertial confinement fission
which nif is doing uh uses external
factors like lasers to compress
something magnetic confinement which
either the big project in France is
using uh uses large magnets generally in
a donut shaped
um configuration to confine and heat the
plasmas so
um two kind of separate branches nif is
inertial confinement uses lasers which
are these basically a building
size laser bank which has these
incredible I mean this is amazing stuff
um uh doped glass amplifiers which with
two Mega Joule capacitors in all through
the room at these these capacitors hold
so much energy that they regularly
explode and they have to be armored so
that the spray shrapnel in weight places
that that won't hurt people
um so amazing technology they take these
lasers 192 beams worth that bounce kind
of go
um back and forth like lasers do picking
up energy
um then gets uh their their frequency
tripled
um it has to be very very high uh
frequency and then shined into a um a
little sleeve a gold sleeve called a
whole rod and this is very much like
what happens in the secondary of a
hydrogen bomb the lasers get converted
to x-rays
and you have this radiation floating
about the radiation pressure
is focused upon a tiny little BB sized
pellet full of hydrogen uh Isotopes yeah
and just Charles sorry to interrupt but
I'm showing this um the image gallery
that you forwarded to me and I'll put
that in the show notes if you're
listening to this on an audio podcast
I'm now just showing um some slides and
images from uh
lasers.ll.nl.gov and I will link to
those in the show notes as well so I'm
showing the BB now the whole ROM
um so what does holaround stand for or
what does it mean is it something it's
the German German term for uh I guess a
some I I don't speak German it's the
reflection room a whole a room with a
hole in it um I'm not exactly sure but
it is the term that was used uh to
describe this and
um that's not the that's the target of
the lasers but the real Ultimate Target
is that pellet yes and so that x-rays
shine on the pellet the
um pellet begins to ablate and uh shoot
stuff off and you get the jet effect and
everything just compresses and if you do
it right you get enough pressure enough
temperature just through the compression
Heating and through the heating of the
plasma
um to get a small fusion reaction and of
course it blows itself apart very
quickly so you have to have enough uh
oomph to get more out than n so the
announcement uh last week was the first
defensible announcement I would say in
either the magnetic or inertial
confinement Fusion sectors
to get more energy out than in and that
comes with a big asterisk but
um the big asterisk is that the way they
Define more out than in in this context
is more energy of laser of fusion out
than laser light m
now the problem with that is lasers are
inefficient
um and it takes a hundred times more
energy to generate the beams than it
takes to
um uh to then then comes out shining so
even if you have that break even uh on
the laser side there's still a huge
strain of energy there on the uh between
the wall plug and the lasers
um aren't accounted for so whether that
is really Break Even well it's it's a
definition that scientists agreed upon
in the late 70s early 80s so it is a
milestone this is I don't want to
diminish that but in terms of reasons
given that I'm sorry to interrupt again
Charles but is it really I mean wait you
described a fusion device a bomb
um you know isn't it true that the net
you know uh production of energy just
wrong energy heat from you know the fat
man or whatever the uh the first Fusion
devices were they had some amount of
input from a fission device that was
lower than what was liberated so it I
mean Tech this wasn't sustained this
isn't connected to you know sdg e here
in San Diego and generating electricity
so is that really true
I mean in in the lab in a controlled
manner you're absolutely right that uh
if you wanted you could have an
underground Cavern assault Cavern and
you detonate Fusion devices and boil
steam in fact yeah uh don Knuckles who
is the architect of this whole ICF thing
was actually investigating as part of
project plowshare the idea of generating
energy by detonating uh hydrogen bombs
it just didn't make sense
to do it but uh you're absolutely right
that I mean you could
uh that is an energy source and that
energy source infusion that was done in
the 50s yeah and I was talking to some
friends over uh uh Shabbat this past
weekend they're all asking me about the
um you know this big breakthrough and
how interesting it is and it is
interesting I guess that technologically
the experimental physicist in me you
know it's delighted and mesmerized by it
on the other hand you know it is and
this is again where your journalistic
expertise positions you in a role That's
Unique in the world I have to say not
with uh you know Untold flattery you
know to get you to follow me on Mastodon
but um but but the but the point being I
made the analogy it's kind of like you
know you're using like your friend
elon's you know magic uh dragon you know
rocket or Falcon rocket and on the side
of it is a match and and it goes up and
as it launches it it rubs against a
piece of you know of of sandpaper
igniting the match and okay so well like
the actual motion that wasn't that
wasn't so much energy to get a little
bit more heat
um but there's you got to build a rocket
you had to put in all the energy to make
this device it's not sustainable it's
not doesn't seem to be like a
technological path forward so is it just
you know quote unquote and again this is
with Incredible respect and admiration
for these colleagues doing the hardest
job you know the most rewarding job in
this sense uh the experimentalist
um but uh is it is it an evolutionary
dead end is there a prospect for for
this to actually any inertial
confinement this one or another to
provide sustainable power in the um you
know foreseeable future
from a power point of view I do think
that this is a dead end
um at least certain certainly this
technology that nif has done I mean the
flash labs are unbelievable however
you've got a room full of glass that
takes a third of a day to cool down and
2.1 megajoules or I guess they could
create a 3.5 megajoules out that's about
what you get by tossing a piece of
kindling in the fire which is all very
nice and good but isn't powering much
okay really really for a a reasonable
ICF power plant you've got to have a
repeat rate in the tens of Hertz so uh
thousands of times a day tens of
thousands of times hundreds of thousands
of times
so um you've got to go to totally
different technology probably solid
state lasers you have to have solid
state lasers and very high frequencies
and so there's so many kind of technical
barriers that haven't been worked out
but this is really not a proof of
principle of anything on the ICF path to
power I would say um
what is it really I mean it's I mean I
think it's significant for nif because
that was a design goal and to have a
four billion dollar project that 12
years after it turned on was unable to
achieve its design goal uh would be a
major black eye for uh Livermore and so
the fact that they finally lived up to
it's not the national threshold of
ignition facility anymore
um is is a major deal for them
um what it means for us
I don't know I mean it's it's
in terms of stockpile stewardship they
are in a new regime I I'm hoping that
they'll be able to increase their gain
significantly over the next few months
and years that they're in a regime where
you're actually getting
significant heating from Fusion which is
new but
for energy not really I'm afraid it's
just not a not helping much what is the
next goal of their research is it to
just improve the cue or the
amplification factor which
um you you've you know characterized
about 50 energy net gain or that's their
characterization what what is there are
they just going to try to increase that
again just shouldn't be demeaning guys
I'm not I'm not diminishing it at all
but is that the main you know technology
kind of um you know forking point that
they're going to pursue are they going
to you know add doubling the lasers and
you know doing something or you know
going to gamma rays instead of X is
there some technological hurdle or is it
more and better of the same
it's more and better of the same
although they they are definitely
they've got this huge parameter space to
fool around with and they're tweaking
all sorts of things not just the aim of
the lasers the power of the lasers the
thickness of the ablator the kind of the
thinness of the shell the fills of the
shell uh whether you put a magnetic
field around it whether you not don't
put a magnetic field around it so
there's lots and lots of things that
they play around with and part of the
issue is that a lot of these experiments
are not very well reproducible that
there's a huge sensitivity to initial
conditions so
um part of the reason that this
um device was created in the first place
is to
experiment throughout parameter space
and figure out so they can simulate
um implosions better which is useful for
weapons design and stockpile stewardship
so what they're really doing is trying
to figure out how to get things what
parameters are really sensitive what
parameters really aren't where are the
simulations failing where are they not
so they've got a lot of science to do
not in the energy domain as much as it
is in kind of understanding this liminal
space which is really kind of
interesting physically and interesting
for weapons just not for energy
I'm showing now some of the videos from
uh secretary granholm's visit there last
week on the 13th
um you know showing some of the the swag
that they gave out and the threshold uh
um uh and going beyond the threshold uh
talk a little bit about some of the
the
um you know kind of Downstream effects
uh uh uh you know and I think about you
know energy and uh and fusion obviously
you can't not think about you know
weapons at some level and I'm wondering
you know is there kind of a potential
beating of uh of Swords into plowshares
moment where we see
that we have fought many resource Wars
around the world and in fact there's
this thing called the resource curse you
know which you've heard about probably
but you know just Loosely explains the
countries that have the most you know
diamonds or oil and stuff they often
have the least tolerant least Democratic
regimes at least open at least to
journalistic freedoms and all sorts of
other things
um from uh you know Tom Memorial now
what if you know the U.S becomes the
world's leader in in generating Fusion
Energy would that happen to us you know
would we would the US become a giant you
know South Africa uh De Beers what are
the implications of this just from a
geopolitical standpoint if you would
well I mean if if one were two great
Fusion Energy I mean it's uh for there
to be this uh resource curse there would
have to be some sort of moat to prevent
others from coming across just like with
nuclear weapons once someone proved it
was able to be done it wasn't all that
hard for others to reproduce
uh the issue so I I
unless there's some sort of Secret Sauce
which is patentable or or
there's some very difficult technical
fix that we keep top secret I it's hard
for me to imagine that there would be
this
um it would become the domain of one
country I I would assume that Europe and
China and other places with the
technical abilities would follow
unfairly quickly so I I don't see a
resource curse even if we get this
working again I I don't see it happening
I I think that the magnetic branch is
more likely than the um uh inertial
Branch uh it happens to be less useful
for uh weapons research which is part of
the reason why it's much more
International
um
and speaking of weapons you know I've
thought and this is just more of a side
trackers and I'll get to talk to you
that often but um you know when you
think about you know I was thinking
recently you know this geopolitical
situation that the world has been
suffering through since February 26th or
Whatever Whenever Putin invaded Ukraine
you know lingering and looming over that
conversation has been this this Dreadful
thought of nuclear war and uh even some
claiming we're already in you know World
War III and it's just a matter of time
before a device is detonated
um some including my friend Eric
Weinstein I'm not gonna dwell on um uh
you know some of the claims that he's
made but at least on his podcast he
called for the resumption of atmospheric
nuclear above ground testing
um as a warning to society to kind of
illustrate the horrors of it
um I don't want to talk about Eric's uh
hopefully he's coming on the podcast
back on the podcast at some point soon
to talk about that and many other things
but I want to ask you um you know I was
thinking you know about the Holocaust
recently and and thinking about well how
visceral it is and except for the
insanity of you know Kanye West by the
way do we have to journalists have to
call them yay I mean like who is this
guy like you have to call him by his
preferred new name because it's he chose
it but he gets anyway I don't get into
that point is
um when we look at uh when we think
about you know what could have what
could happen uh what did happen during
the Holocaust one of the most you know
kind of poignant outcomes of it has been
the portrayal of it in society and the
awareness of it uh and how and how awful
and Doc and and well documented it was
in fact uh things from the butterfly
project started here in San Diego
documenting 1.5 million uh Jewish
children exterminated all the way up
Schindler's List obviously the Holocaust
music anyway do we need some sort of
like nuclear Holocaust Museum and do we
have any uh equivalent or would it be
useful to kind of just just really
relate to humanity how horrific and and
awful any kind of you know well nuclear
war is winnable no it's not I mean yeah
okay you could say tactically whatever
the Russians have some plants but anyway
Charles do we need some kind of
education you know kind of tantamount
I'm not asking to speculate on the
morality of of the Hiroshima Nagasaki
device that happened to think that they
were but but let's not get into that but
do we need education about the horrors
of it and could these technologies that
we're now talking about could they be a
tool to educate the public
oh yeah I mean you and you and I grew up
in a moment when we couldn't forget
about nuclear weapons I mean the Cold
War was hot and
um we heard about the Cuban Missile
Crisis we didn't hear about uh Abel
Archer uh in 1983.
um but we know about it now and I think
that it does seem a little remote to us
in a way that sounds that feels
dangerous
um I wish we did have a little bit more
understanding of the horrors of these
these weapons I think part of it is I
mean we are uh hamstrung partially by
the fact that of nations in the world
who have used these weapons and anger we
are the only ones
um so I think that it doesn't dwell in
our psyche in the way that it does say
for the Japanese
um
I think it is a bad thing that I mean I
similarly with I think with the uh as
the Holocaust Survivors the last ones
die out that we as a Society are in
danger of losing our historical memory
um so and I I I would be in favor of
anything we can do to kind of get uh get
an immediacy to our kids to understand
that this is part of what they have to
live with even if they don't see it
yeah I think that's um you know that's
kind of the obligation of an educator is
to is to really you know bring these
things home but but in a way that um you
know is is done in a controlled fashion
but also is is visceral I mean we know
from being Educators uh although I don't
know I was never taught it I learned it
on the job but uh but you know the most
the most Vivid and permanent
demonstrations are are those and you
know that adhere to Maslow's hierarchy
of needs including you know the the
removal of threats against safety and
then conversely I suppose that if you
really visualize how awful something
could be you'd be less likely to employ
it so I know we only have a few minutes
before I have to go light my Hanukkah
candles using my Fusion reactor you can
see it behind me in the background I
actually did a video recently about
heavy water using deuterium uh to make
ice cubes uh that uh that sink instead
of float and that was really fun
um but uh but I guess the the last
question I wanted to to kind of delve
into is you know where where would you
like to see this go if you were you know
um you know not uh not I don't want to
say some eccentric billionaire but could
you could you think of a way uh that you
would like to see this going with not
unlimited resources but you know
billions of dollars private sector
public sector where do you see it
well I'd love to see kind of a a
a reasonable coherent plan of when we
can respectively get this on the grid in
a solution
um and I I right now I mean we we
haven't had a Kitty Hawk moment where
you get wings off the ground so it's uh
honestly I think it belongs as part of a
larger portfolio of dealing uh how we
are going to deal with climate change in
the next five years 10 years 20 years
and that includes a portfolio of
um technologies that are here now uh
technologies that are a bit of a stretch
and that's not just on the uh supply
side but on on demand side as well as
kind of geoengineering I mean we've got
to open those discussions
um as sad as it is so um
I want I want Fusion to take its place
within the larger portfolio rather than
kind of being a techno fix uh that seems
to solve everything I mean there's
there's an old story
um and I'm not sure whether it's true or
nabos it was I think it was uh told by I
think I think it was Martin Luther King
but I got the AAA
um person on death row
um kind of marching towards death row
he's muttering under his breath save me
Joe Lewis save me Joe Lewis uh I mean
for me kind of
clutching at Fusion as this
technological save all is as futile as
kind of having their Heroes step in and
kind of magically whisk you away from
Death Row we've got to really work on on
practical Solutions and while Fusion may
be there in 30 years we need something
sooner
great um so there's a couple questions
and folks that are online on YouTube you
can ask a couple more questions there's
some debate back and forth whether or
not we could ever ramp up tritium
production uh substantially so I
couldn't make a tritium heavy water ice
cube for a variety of reasons one is
it's radioactive but the other it's
controlled and it's a very expensive is
tritium a bottleneck and then just to
remind my audience you can ask more
questions for a couple more minutes
yeah it's a bottleneck now
um because we have a limited Supply but
once you have neutrons you can kind of
generate tritium to some extent
especially when you have uh adequate uh
supplies of lithium
um so I'm less worried about kind of the
the materials part the fuel than I am
about the process itself
and then uh this is a question how much
energy would be used if you could do
this I suppose to split water into
hydrogen and deuterium I guess the
question would be you know could you
attach your Fusion reactor you know
energy source coming out the back end
and then put it into a centrifuge you
know it's just series of centrifuges
what what is the potential I mean
desalination of the ocean uh scrubbing
the atmosphere of carbon dioxide do you
think these will ever come true uh are
these things that will that will likely
materialize or not really a good
question I mean I I the first the first
thing that comes to mind is
desalinization if you have Infinite
Energy desalinization and carbon
scrubbing and things like that
my big question is can civilization hold
on long enough until we get to the point
where we can get there
um and also honestly I I wonder whether
we have a society that would allow
um kind of a free energy solution or
whether we kind of always have
commercial barriers uh to kind of this
this paradise that people see and it's
like it's not like Star Trek where it
can all drop uh the idea of money and we
can uh get Earl Gray tea just by Pure
Energy
um of course it's theoretically there
but I I the way we humans behave I I
think scarcity is built into our bones
and I I'm not sure we'd let go of it so
quickly yeah that might be
um so let's see thorium reactors talk
about Thorium reactors Charles any
interest that you have there from uh
this is from let's go this is from a
Golem we've got mitzvah's Golem in the
in the house tonight I'm it's supposed
toxic mayak um what do you think about
Thorium as a thorium fueled sodium cold
reactors
Advanced fuel cycle reactors are really
really interesting I think Pebble bed
reactors I think even kind of
traditional kind of uh uranium low
enriched uranium with Advanced designs I
think those are worth exploring and
worth doing something uh especially
since they're the uh they're mirror term
than than uh Fusion is so again I think
I think it fits very nicely into that
Niche
um that Fusion occupies but because
Fusion is so beautiful on idea it's kind
of crowded out everything because it
seems like the ideal technofix uh where
there's stuff like this out there that's
probably
and then the last question uh I'm going
to ask using my host prerogative
um totally pivoting now the state of
Journalism today so we've seen
journalism kind of assailed from many
different angles uh we've seen you know
posts and and accusations uh you know
from places like journalists on on
Twitter complaining about Twitter as I
you know tweeted the other day you know
Twitter sucks he tweeted you know and
and I know you have you know kind of
found it much less hospitable uh I've
tried to set up Mastodon I've been
banned from truth social uh what what
does the landscape look at what are you
teaching your students what are they um
what do they feel about this profession
that they've uh you know uh admittedly
tried to become a part of there's a lag
and time between what they wanted to do
four years ago and maybe the way things
are now so talk about the landscape talk
about your um your how you're dealing
with all these you know radical changes
on a daily basis depending on how much
diet coke uh certain South African uh
billionaires have
yeah no no it may live in interesting
times uh yeah it's it's
kind of the culmination of uh of a lot
of things have been rocking journalism
for the past 20 years and because we
were talking about scarcity that the
digital environment it creates
post-scarcity for uh information uh
technology that you you can you no
longer have to have a physical paper or
a uh delivered uh it's uh can be copied
indefinitely without without anyone
paying so that kind of broke the journal
as a model and we've kind of been
writing from fad to fad
um trying to figure out how to make
money despite the fact that
um
are our chief
um uh asset was an audience that we
could sell things to and other people
have basically been able to duplicate
that and we can no longer sell for a
subscription model very easily
um Twitter uh happened to be a niche
where
um
we as an industry did not kind of come
up with a good infrastructure where we
could disseminate our work uh in a smart
way so we kind of have been peggybacking
to our uh mistake I think uh on Facebook
and on Twitter and we learned very
quickly how
hostile uh Facebook was it took a little
longer to figure out how hostile Twitter
is so I I mean I think that this is a
reckoning that's been happening in slow
motion for 20 years and I don't think
that it's over by any stretch I don't
think Mastodon is an answer I don't
think post is an answer
um we have to figure out how to maintain
our audiences maintain the trust in the
audiences even as our audiences get more
uh schismatic which is really really
hard it's hard to do a broadcast
when the audience is in two different
places we can't capture capture everyone
we want no absolutely all right well
Charles uh I want to thank you so much
professor Charles seif New York
University the best university one of
the best universities in the world uh
and uh and and are true a true thought
leader someone who has an old-fashioned
newspaper man you know I know you've got
one of those Tweed hats in addition you
know with the card says press and then
and you break that out with your tweed
jacket as a professor I want to remind
you if you are interested in getting
exotic materials uh shipped to you I
won't make it into time for Hanukkah or
Christmas but these are fragments of a
meteorite highly magnetized meteorite
that landed some four billion years ago
and the Americas in in Argentina uh join
my mailing list I have a link up there
briancating.com list please leave a
review wherever you're watching this
thumbs up if you like this if you'd like
to see some more videos with with
Charles I can read more of his books uh
he's got another phenomenal book called
zero which is about the dangerous idea
of zero we've had on uh Charles twice
now maybe I'll come back for a third
time but let me know what you thought of
this episode and if you'd like to see
more on these live conversations with
thought leaders and and truly a generous
generous Scholars I think of you when I
think about what should a scholar be at
somebody like you Charles so I want to
thank you so much wish you a happy
holiday season happy New Year and I hope
we can talk next year and may we have
nuclear Feud may we have you know
thousands of flowers blooming without
any booms right Charles
hopefully and thank you very much and
hugs Amaya hugs America Merry Christmas
to my other listeners out there and uh
happy new year and we've got a couple
more episodes to come today we had
Edward Frankel on uh and uh next week
we're going to have on Stacy McGaw
talking about uh Monde alternatives to
Dark Matter big dark matter you know
there's anti-dark matter there's Pro
Dark Matter uh maybe we'll use that to
run a superfusion reactors I don't know
I'm just making it up uh we'll have on a
couple more UFO episodes and and
possibly one uh more before the end of
the year thanks everybody thanks for
tuning in good night bye Charles good
night thank you